hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today i am talking to my
friend grant kirkhope who uh hasn't
worked on anything of note
not ever really no no no not very nice
no no i'm very unnoteworthy unknown
worthy as they say is that real words
composers go yeah i run it because
you're a composer so uh grand people who
don't know who you are what have you
worked on
oh guess what from the beginning i guess
goldeneye and bunty kazooie um donkey
kong 64 and perfect dark um banjo-tooie
and uh
i always forget that you did kings of
the level i love that uh everyone
forgets that one uh mario rabbids
kingdom battle currently working on
uh married ever sparks of hope i did
minecraft
you have to pay me for us to make this
zoom call happy exactly [ __ ]
it grandchildren cheap either
but genuinely i mean you uh
have had like you had your music shaped
my childhood effectively in a way that
is like
so wild to think about i was listening
to that goldeneye soundtrack all the
time have you seen that that viral tick
tock recently yeah it's crazy it's funny
how something's catch on his name go
crazy but that just went ballistic how
did you feel about that well i think
it's cool that people care what i do you
know but is that how that that paul's
menu music song was made oh exactly yeah
nothing like that
you're in dev now you know what it's
like
it's true um but i guess i the the part
of the reason why i want to talk to you
right now we've been wanting to do this
for ages really uh was because
banjo-kazooie just came out on switch
again today i'm a huge banjo fan i'm a
huge gold knife fan huge perfect dark
fan all of them um all of them but i
have no idea how like you go about you
know creating some of the most iconic
songs from the n64 era like where do you
start on something like the banjo theme
how does that even begin yeah like you
sort of say like i know what i was doing
like you know
we got we got a thing right i started
around 95 before you're born clearly i'm
like i'm sure i was
exactly
i mean you know it's my first game i got
to myself so i did goldeneye first with
uh graham norgate we did it together and
then banjo was the first coming did all
the music all the sound effects where i
did the whole thing
so like you know i didn't know what i
was doing like i was doing a goal today
either you just
i accidentally just think that's my goal
and i was so good because none of the
depth i made a game before and it was
hard oh i didn't know that no none of
the team won golden i had so it's like
it's like
so it's a bit like you just shut your
eyes and hope for the best right don't
you so i mean worked out pretty well
yeah but i mean sometimes i think
because you don't you don't know what
the rules are
you just do what you think right i think
once you get the rules put in place it
all goes a bit wrong
i have i've had that conversation with
people multiple times where it's like i
think there are benefits to not knowing
the rules of things or how things are
made because then you can just do
whatever you want and you don't think
about other people's opinions or
restrictions and you just kind of like
and here's god and i yeah but i think i
think that's really true like i hate it
when it gets too organized i like you
know when you get these the games that
get focus group tested and all that
nonsense that goes on with you and it's
it kind of pleases a lot of people a
little bit but not but not many people a
lot you know efficiently kind of it gets
all diluted down get games made by a by
committee rather than a single vision
and when i was back at rare
you know all the best games that i've
worked on you've got that one you know
main league designer great director
who's got a real strong vision and
that's those are the best games i've
ever worked i think like nick into banjo
greg males who was the guy that did they
did it rare for
way before i started very young he did
the donkey kong country and did he come
to quest and you know all those you know
those games were like revolutionary when
they first came out yeah and then he
went off to do
um he started dreaming before banjo
right which was dream before that and
all that
you know the story that went on there so
i got to banjo i could i just kind of
thought
i'd gone from writing this kind of
rpg-ish music for dream which i thought
was kind of zelda sort of stuff and then
tim stamper was a god of rare you know
said to me um right need to have some
track some platforms and i had no idea
what platform how to do it i never
didn't he asked for platformer music
yeah because for banjo all right so yeah
and i was like all right so i needed to
write so that i just wrote a tune that i
thought was platforming it was actually
click clock woods so i wrote that that
was the first piece that i wrote it was
just a general piece it wasn't supposed
to be the click clock was it so you
wrote it based on the genre and not on
like the characters or seeing
environment art right interesting yes i
just did that and then you know the game
started and said that sounds about right
you know so i was i was trying to
keep my job right i don't even know a
short period of time i thought
[ __ ] it up i'm probably gonna get fired
you know
so um you know and jane wise was there
we're gonna beat them and say great
morgans are all great composers i was
the last guy in the door at the time you
know as a composer so you know it's a
bit scary when you've got dave weiss up
there right chilling out this amazing
stuff robbie's doing killer instinct and
graham's doing um
he was doing a blast call and golden eye
you know and all that it's a bit like
you know
what am i gonna do what the [ __ ] do i
know you know so you know it's pretty
crazy that it ended up all right really
that was this truck but i just i just
thought that i you know we're trying to
beat mario 64 that's what we're trying
to beat right you know that's
interesting
yeah
and i mean like we've all got n64s given
by the company we all have got married
which is forced to be over all playing
it and loving it you know and i kind of
thought there's no point me trying to
write that kind of puppy jazz that
nintendo did so well because
because hey cody condo is like the jedi
master and i'm just a padawan right you
know and how i come crap at writing
poppies you ask i totally crap i just
had to try and find something that was
not that so interesting i just stumbled
across that kind of woman
that well it sort of came from danny
open sort of that kind of batman
in batman i'm not sorry beetlejuice he
got that
i kind of picked up on that and it kind
of bled into banjo and then the tritone
thing went on let me know what that is
but that's it you know so it's different
two notes that are far apart
i didn't know that there you go
i'll compose
right the furthest point between those
two notes is an f sharp it's a it's an
augmented fourth right it's a flat fifth
so as i can see to see in the furthest
away from the c is the f sharp before it
starts to get closer to the next note
interesting i mean right so i kind of
thought that mimicked banjo kazooie
banjo's dumb because it was sarcastic
miles apart and things i kind of thought
and so that all kind of just kicked off
that whole weird sort of uh i don't know
what you call it um quirky sound that
the music has worked that was one of
those cases where usually when you do
something like that the artist will do
the graphics first and you'll do the
music later but that was when i did the
music first and then the guys put the
graphics together like so kind of this
idea of like playing different
instruments between the different
characters
and then at bryan he did that he was a
artist and that bit put the rest of it
together and it came out like it was so
then it's just that classic kind of band
that did a little bit a little bit a
little it's a kind of thing that abandon
your plays
you know if you heard it just something
well to me it was i thought if that's
real but that's what i thought about
yourself like so you know it's just like
that so you know
it's just like shut your eyes and what's
it sound like and off you go that's
weird it's interesting like what you're
saying is really just like well you know
i had this thought that i had this
thought and then i kind of threw
something together how many iterations
did that song or or do any of the iconic
songs that you you've made go through
i think that was probably one that's
probably no way yeah like a lot i'm a
thing on me right i'd speak faster than
everything really fast i just kind of
off i go so i get really excited
the only things that i changed in i
think in banjo really was i had a
different tune from mumbai's mountain
and a different tune for treasure to
have cove
and then towards the end of the game
chris stamper whose time stamps was
brother they're the guys that run rare
so we
because i kind of found that that
quirkiness later in the music
i didn't get it at the start i said what
you should go back and change those two
and i was like what i just spent all
this spending time writing this music
and now i'm about to change it it's
nearly coming out you know so i went
back and changed uh mumbai's mountain to
me more up that more like quirky style
and also if you go inside the ant hill
on the first level that's the original
theme for that level just slowed down
yeah would you say so i left it in there
um and then treasure trove was a bit
like a beach boy's white pouty sort of
thing um
i had a kind of guitar breakdown in the
middle of it well you know samples
yeah uh but then i changed it to what
what it is now which is more it's kind
of based on the main theme really so
that makes sense my favorite song from
banjo is uh i believe it's in tui it's
the the grotto that i see cave i don't
remember exactly what it's called so is
that hellfire peaks icy yes is it
bizarre cause that kind of felt the two
that people
cause it was we we thought you know with
with budget huge tui fan grant
i love chewie well that's so bizarre
because i kind of felt like we thought
make the game twice the size it's gonna
be twice as good it just wasn't because
it was so hard to get you so hard to get
around it to navigate it's pretty you
can get lost
i've never finished it so i finished
banjo-kazooie i don't know a million
times um i've never finished tui and i
think tui came out at the a time that
was like
when i was old enough to understand
puzzles i feel like i flailed my way
around kazooie and then tui was the game
that like i was old enough to understand
so i have this thing where i've
intentionally never finished that game
because in my head and i know this is
stupid um i feel like that would be me
signing off on my childhood i refuse to
finish banjo-tooie i play it frequently
i go back all the time but i don't want
to roll credits on that game
meaning i will never see your name in
any association with it whatsoever uh
because i don't i don't want to
get if it would feel like i was rolling
credits on the excitement that i had of
discovering that game as a kid so i
refused to finish mojo tui
that's
crazy
it was enough that like i think i was
six when i played kazooie right so like
i still played it
uh but i don't think that i i think that
i probably
got through things by accident whereas
two-way i understood what i was doing
right and it's like formative there for
me and like obviously i played tons of
perfect dark and and golden eye with my
sister like that was such a big part of
my childhood in a way that's that's so
cool and that's that's the thing about
those two um those three four games that
we're talking about there that's
interesting is like they don't even
necessarily sound like they came from
the same composer
do you feel like you have a distinct
style or was it like
you know you just understood the the
needs of the project or was there a lot
of input from people at rare like how
how much effort do you put into making
sure that things sound um
like distinct to each game or how does
that get formulated well i don't know
you know i have to get us down i kind of
think that people have got this kind of
cocopean sound and like you know it's
like not intentional it just comes out
the way it does right i always think
like if you know if i i'm a metal i'm
out of guitar i'm not head right so i
always think to myself
i can spot anybody on a mile away
interesting just because you know he is
vibrato the way he plays it's so
distinctive and like brian made equally
they just he can't miss brian may if
it's one note even he can't miss him
he's he just got that real built in that
bit of built in style and that's what i
feel like
a lot of composers
like it or not it just comes like you
have a certain way and i think if you've
learned a certain way then yeah i i get
that but i feel i feel like kingdoms of
amyloid sounds very different to
banjo-kazooie
yeah but i mean it's gonna do right but
i mean i guess for me i still spot the
same chord sequences that i like to use
yeah i can still spot that but like you
know when i get back to being a music
colleague and do the degree like i was
[ __ ] at harmony like i failed the
harmony exam
three three years out of four i was so
bad at composing never one stop that
didn't compose i never went into my head
no way not at once i mean you know for
me to end up being a composer and the
people to even like what i do is just
ridiculous really
i'm so bad at it i don't know how this
completely worked out really so then
what was your actual job title when you
joined rap it was composer sound
designer all right there you go that's
but no but i spent a year like you know
my friend robin bean land right he did
kind of
mates we played local rock bands
together in north yorkshire in england
and like he announced one day you've got
a job right you know like i know that
and you've got a job you're just playing
in bands and sounds
yeah yeah i've done it for 11 years for
website you know something employment
then went played in bands and [ __ ] like
that so i couldn't believe it and after
you've been a year and a half
you've been on unemployment
in the first place really
uh how did you manage it like what was
it like when you first joined
how did that happen no
so he just so he's recommend somebody
bought a synthesizer and a copy of
cubase and bits and a crappy atari st
with a meg of ram you know and mega ram
in this nice um you know a whole meg a
whole egg
like writing tunes that i thought were
appropriate for video games over the
course of 1994. i played a lot of games
at the time you know and said rare five
cassette tapes i never got a reply and
then out of the blue i've got a letter
saying please come into you and dave
white's interview but i got the job
couldn't believe it you sent five
cassette tapes that's so funny
94 yeah i've never been my mother i
still have my mother at 33 for christmas
i was 33 still at home yeah
that's
yeah i mean right smart
it wouldn't work these days
no i don't think so uh so how much of
your job at rate was also sound design
about half an hour usually it really got
a whole game each so you did all the
sound all the sound effects all the
music right it changed it changed a bit
later because
i ended up getting i got given.com 64
and perfect dark and banjo-2 in the same
year oh my god so when we did music on
perfect dark and uh dr confused before
us did all the all the sound effects and
music on london too it's a tough year
it's because graham norgat left and quit
rare gotcha he went to
he went into form uh to help form free
article and do um
you know what did they do he gave him
time splits yeah so so lex his game to
the left so
um he was doing um he did jeffress
gemini and the dark and robin did
jefferson
perfect dark on top of a bunch of tui
so it's been a tough year
and how did you approach um doing sound
design for banjo like i feel like
i i guess at the time goldeneye and
perfect dark were also super iconic in
terms of sound but now in my head like a
lot of the sound that's used in those
games is used in other form formats as
well whereas banjo is like
i feel like i remember reading that you
had a hand in the way that the dialogue
is delivered
yeah we did that yeah like and also all
the silly little noises like the little
things it was just
me most of the time making noises in
their mic in my office
basically because it's just no one
wanted to do it certainly and i just
i'll have to do it because it's got to
be done right yeah yeah and then tim was
quite keen to get the
the the things to talk about there's no
memory space
we wouldn't make a bit on
all the music and all that sound effects
that was everything in that one mega bit
so i you know it came with this idea of
like going making funny noises and then
you'd kind of
run do random pitch and random select
from a batch of sound interesting so it
used to be like that so and i sort of
learned that having a massive pitch
range with sounding [ __ ] because the
human voice can't do that you can't go
like you don't do that naturally so it's
a very narrow pitch thing and some
characters work better with a lot of
samples like because we had quite a lot
of samples and banjo would only have a
few and that was just like just making
funny noises and sticking them together
i like doing the the you mean i could i
was i was one but you know i'd do the
evening and all that nonsense you know
so like i thought that that was a real
thought if it's totally [ __ ] it sounds
totally awful but it's the best we can
do wow i never forget when i went for
the to do the first meeting with davide
soliani for ramon brio for the um
uh my rabbit's game yeah yeah they sort
of said to me yeah that's so iconic is
that panda because
it's true though
so this is so funny to talk to you about
because it's like something that you've
done that is so iconic and so beloved
and you are 100 percent like ah i'm just
sitting in a room i don't know i know i
mean we all thought was [ __ ] like just
this is awful wild to think about people
are going to be so pissed as to doing
this you know i mean i guess yeah
without
nothing like that existed at the time
and without the context of the game like
it's like the the sounds are so strange
and you could like
out of context would be grading like
it's really odd but it works so well and
i'm like so glad that it exists the way
that it does it's like how do you feel
about it now like are you still like eh
well i i guess i don't hear that often
so you know um but i think i did the
kazooie
when she runs we thought this is going
to really go on people's tits they're
going to not relax at all but it was all
right in the end you know
it was because i haven't really thought
this is going to be particularly
annoying for people i'm not going to
like it they're going to turn it off you
know
so i don't remember any of the sound
being annoying that's crazy yeah you
were younger at the time let's face it
yeah but i still play it like it's still
good i'll do it really yeah what what do
you play the entity forward should you
play the xbox version what do you play
generally the xbox version well rather
yes um and i mean i i still think
perfect dark is an incredible game like
i still think playing through that
campaign i mean not that banjo isn't as
well but yeah generally um we'll play
rare replay but i do still have my 64
and i i brought it with me to the us
with that collection of games because
again the thing with tui is that i have
that save on that one physical all right
you know cartridge that is like again
it's very sentimental but i'm like this
is my childhood and i must protect it
like it must stay here and and maintain
so yeah i still have my n64 um i don't
feel like i'll ever get rid of it i mean
it just shaped so many people and and
i don't know i just
i don't know how to to ask because i
understand your perspective that you're
like i don't know we just kind of did it
it's like how do you ever ever think
about the amount of people
who um
i credit the 64 and rare in that era for
getting me to literally where i am today
that's why i think i ended up in the
games industry like do you ever take the
time to think about
the impact that you had so i mean
sometimes i get almost when we were
there right rare was a very very secret
company wouldn't it did no interviews do
nothing and like no one knew who we were
like tim somebody still said we're not
pop stars we just made games let's let
the game do the talking there's nobody
to do any interviews at all like that
and that's what it was right so what's
going to turn them into the us that i
kind of thought oh people seem to know
my name from not not like it's like is
it billions of people
oh you're that blood that did you know
and i was like all right you know so it
kind of started to sink in a little bit
when i got to go to the u.s in 2008. um
you know so i mean
that's so it it didn't sink in until
2008. not really no no no no because you
know i guess
there's no internet really back you know
i guess i guess so yeah you have to wait
for the magazines to review a month
later it wasn't that instant it's a hit
it's a fail that's where it is now you
know so
you know i feel like
you know like but what i gathered what i
get now is that it's like all those
things when you're about five to fifteen
or whatever somewhere in that age group
you you remember
like i remember all the cartoons i used
to watch all the steam tunes that have
lyrics you that stuff never leads you to
the that you die yeah i agree there's a
really specific age range where that
exists and you just let go of it yeah
and i think you never forget that like
for me scooby-doo or thunderbirds or
whatever it is yeah um you know and i
feel like
that's that's the way it is i suppose
it's taking those people to get to the
age where they can find me on the
internet
you know
so i guess it's
it just seems to be like this i'm in
this kind of moment right now where
i'm i'm get i'm reasonably well known
because people go oh yeah you did that
thing you know i liked that back then
you know you know i mean it's a bit like
that so i caught up to you really slowly
that's really interesting yeah yeah so i
never really you know i'd like 10 if i
was on twitter or something ridiculous
you know you know that's my mom and well
not my mother my family or whatever you
know that was it right and all of a
sudden people start to find you don't
it's a bit of a crazy thing but i really
feel that rare had a real golden time
about it absolutely i still think
pre-microsoft red no shade to them now i
think sea of thieves is great but it's
still my favorite studio of all time
yeah i just i know i think for my friend
robin to go there out of the blue
and just go why don't you try and work
there what an absolute ridiculous you
know thing if he hadn't done it and
suggested i've never done it i've been
playing i said we didn't put rock for 35
quid a night now probably you know you
know
slightly balding you know i mean so it's
like it's a bit like
it's it's funny how
and i really could do that to the two
brothers and chris stamper they had such
a
i just think they're both geniuses like
i loved working for those guys
absolutely adored it like when i got
there dkc had just come out oh dc2 was
just about to come out um they've been
on the news in the uk because nintendo
bought 49 of the company yeah it was a
big deal that nintendo never did that up
for a western developer never ever
bought anybody outside outside of japan
you know like it was crazy and like it
just it was just like been in disneyland
it was you know all these all these and
all these teams also pretty in his old
farm houses like there's all bombs all
set apart with with cody key so you
couldn't get into anybody else's barn so
you couldn't see what the teams were
doing it's all we're all sort of
slightly in competition with each other
you know even internally yeah yeah the
keys wouldn't get us into any of them
any of the bars
so you know like just
all that it was like magic
and everything came out just was just a
hit you know
it was it was yeah and they still hold
up it's i know yeah
to get to do banjo and dk and perfect
dark you know
was ridiculous like i love doing perfect
dark it's so different for me to do
something electronic and yeah again i
thought i don't know what i'm doing i
like the x-files at the time i'll do
something a bit like that that's what i
thought you know our x-files kind of
blade runnery so that's what i was
thinking at the time you know but i
didn't really know
um
you know you know it's it's just
ridiculous that you end up there it's
complete robin did it then i did it and
then just bizarre what was it like to
work on um goldeneye especially as like
a british boy i don't know how it was
for that studio to get to work on a bond
property but i know that like that you
know my my family's british my
granddad's british and he's a huge bond
fan
i feel like i wasn't part of his legacy
like did that does that mean something
extra special at the time
oh absolutely like for me i guess at my
age like you know when i was a kid you
know when the bomb really came out for
that year it was the biggest thing of
the year yes music best effects best
everything best action you know so to
get to do that was like a man if i got
that i was doing converting dave wise's
did did he come to quest from this super
nes to work on the original four four
channel game boy right the great the
grey breaker that's my first job right
which is pretty tedious and hard and
i've never done it before and i was i
just thought i'd like to rely on it it's
too difficult because although in hex
there was no notes it was like type
numbers into a screen and make it work
like how the [ __ ] can do that you know
it's like programming yeah yeah it was
totally that there was no music it was
just all numbers on a black black in my
screen that was it right you know so and
then it was agreed that um i was allowed
to do the game boy in the morning and
because great i'm sorry greg norgate
said i'm really busy on blast corps i
think he's doing kevin griffey baseball
on the snares he says can you help out
i'm on gold and i'll i'm busy on the
rest of you you can take over with your
last night are you kidding me i couldn't
believe it you know so i
of all the pop songs that pc did the
movies i listened to all of those over
and over again and i love john barry
because he's just a fantastic composer
so i was just like messing around
thinking no i did that whole thing with
a the faith no more drum beat for the
philosopher the uh frigate
all that nonsense and the deranged
around stabs and you know just took it
all together and had a fantastic fun
doing it yeah i bet yeah yeah yeah i
mean just you know you know you can't
believe it can you but the game took
such a long time to make
and it was supposed to be at the same
time the movie it was like how long did
it take to make oh i can't remember it
was forever like it was supposed to be
out when golden i came out i assume yeah
and i remember we got we got in fact
they all got invited for our work that
they'll get invited down towards
fulfillment of the cough goal than
either did it at the pinewood wherever
it was in the uk
and then i remember i got i got to go
down to watching some of the next movie
which is the world is not enough is that
whatever it was well they're like carbon
it sounds right yeah i can't remember
whatever the next one is yeah but like
you know and we were still working on it
we're going to invite you down towards
the film in the next movie to make me
meet peace brosnan and do it you know
we've got going to be got a museum there
all the bond big which is just amazing
and like just crazy you know he was
doing that scene on the motorbike where
he wasn't seeing the movies he gets you
got a japanese lady in the back and he
goes on the side oh yeah yeah
yeah right they were filming that scene
like when you see it getting filled with
that it's so crap compared to what it
looks like yes i've been to a few film
sets and it's like the thing is yeah it
never looks cool no um but the
helicopter
it was just an empty shell no blades no
building
not that we can talk the whole of the
games industry watching a video game get
made is like this is garbage like it's
not like watching games made is this
epic cool thing until the last moment
where you're like oh it came together oh
and i like a man just like i had a
friend of mine who uh andrew robertson
he was a
website against jail strike for years at
um
computer games video in the uk with the
title now he wants to look at playtonic
to work on the first ukulele
it's just not what you think it's going
to be it's pretty boring like it's just
a long time i've just done oh god he
would turn him through it but you don't
find that like now you're dead i agree
yeah i i would agree that it is it is uh
not what i pictured at all and and the
thing is
we're here to talk about you but the one
thing that stood out to me the most
about working in dev versus working in
media is how much i didn't know and how
weird it is that the people that we
listen to to talk about video games as
experts i haven't made them
and i can't like now i did that for
eight years but now i have the
perspective i'm like why did anybody
listen to anything i ever said like why
are we listening to people who
sure i had a journalism degree but i
didn't do game dev why was i listening
to me talk about games it's very strange
now to be like
like you know the youtubers the media i
i still value everything that they do
but like to be like we listen to them as
though they are experts on a thing that
they have never done and it's really
strange um how quickly i was like
what the [ __ ] was what i was so wrong
about so much [ __ ] all the time
and i still am learning so much you know
it's it's um my second year now and it's
still just full of like every day of
just learning
from the i don't know 600 ish people
who have just these
intense areas of expertise which is my
favorite part is a lot to learn no i
think i do think that you get
a lot of smart people on games for sure
i love that everyone's smarter than me
and that's the best i always follow that
i guess i still feel that like that you
know and i kind of feel like i need this
little bit you know
to make the whole picture come together
you know kind of thing totally um but i
do think that the you know
like i guess you'll notice that when
your games come out and they get slagged
off the first they come out and it's
just it just dies right it just goes
away right and i can't i always go on
the dev team for [ __ ] sake you know
and i kind of feel like i don't think
any dev team ever sets out to make a
[ __ ] game no no one does but like
there's often things especially in the
corporate how cooperate it is now you
know you just have to do the thing
you're told to do or and that's
just
a draft idea he's got he just got to do
it right yeah i think a thing that um
i've known this for a while just like by
virtue of visiting so many studios or
having so many friends who work in dev
why didn't the dev team just do this and
it's always like i promise you if you've
thought about it so did somebody on that
team yeah it didn't work it was too
expensive and exec said no like there is
a reason there was there is never a why
didn't they just do this that somebody
at the studio had not thought of um and
that's i mean definitely i think you're
probably right that as things are
getting more and more cooperative it is
just people doing what they're told yeah
and i kind of feel if you think of
devastated ladder right i'm just kidding
all the steps of the ladder kind of feel
like the first step of the first run you
take out in the studio into the
management area of it all all games
knowledge seems to cease to exist in a
way it's like you get that yeah
you get the execs going oh should we
listen to that marketing
do you know just can you pay attention
for five minutes you know if you realize
that that's a completely [ __ ] idea
this is not going to work for anybody
and just let us make it it'll be fine
but the good thing about rare ones
with nintendo was that because they
intended only unfortunately of the
company yeah he couldn't really bully us
along so in tim stanford but took all
the heat from from rare was always late
with the games right and they used to
say the game's going to be out when it's
done and ready because you had a
cartridge then right you couldn't fix it
later they were always very very good
yeah there's no download like you could
yes no patches you know so it's a bit
like
that's the way you make the best games
yeah totally well that's why i kind of
like the indie sector because you know
you've already got the indie part of gdc
and you see the guys get up and talk
they would say i was gonna make a game
in six months or like five years later
they're still making it like you know
but it came out when it was good and
done and ready right and i really like
that the win i went i don't know where
that works that when i was at rare first
like it rare all the guys who sat at
home on spectrum's brightness assembler
and the game where the good programmers
are rare in the internet how big were
the teams because i also feel like
that's probably part of it is i imagine
ray had a smaller teams back
fifteen people each that's all it was
that's so wild i can't believe it
and even to think about what you did on
those games to think that you were a
composer sound designer technically
voice actor uh your audio director um
the amount of roles that you know that
we would have at sms or that any tripoli
studio would have to fit the amount of
[ __ ] that you did on those games this
could be like a hundred people like
i think you just sort of like i don't
know maybe this like that's so wild and
obviously it worked it's um it's
definitely an interesting thing to think
about richard no i mean it's i think you
know like you know when i did the dump
voice kind of thing and it did that
because nobody just wanted to do it i
was like
i'll just do it voice actor as well
it'll be quick right and then nintendo
uses samples and games after that and i
was like what sure this is [ __ ] why are
you doing that you know it's just you
know
it's just it's necessity i think about
that you did it because nobody wanted to
do it it's like i'll do it bollocks to
it it's wild to think about so how do
you feel about how your job has changed
obviously you know you're still working
as a composer on video games how do you
feel about the way that it's changed
over the last 20 years i don't think the
way i do it's changed at all i just i'm
still messing around with you i just you
know like my sample and a french one or
something and mess around until i like
it get a chord sequence or a tune i like
and then
i'm not a very intellectual composer i'm
afraid i'm not like that and i'm sort of
more of a mess around instinctual thing
that it you know that's how i kind of
get to it
the technology's changed i guess you
know it's all better and they've got
these great big huge sample libraries
orchestra i'm sure austin told you about
that all that kind of stuff you know you
know you would get to go and record live
orchestras these days and for god's sake
that's just ridiculous i mean you know i
mean i was i started around 95 and i was
recording the obstacle pinata maybe like
2005 so within 10 years it had gone from
basic grade break game boy
vaguely paying attention to the
orchestra so i could i could do it you
know i mean i think it's not that easy
to jump really um
so
jumping off of that what went into uh
for anyone who doesn't know uh i just
caught it's just called banjo kazooie
rejigged
just sticky dragon you just released so
like what went into making that like
what made you want to make that and how
different was that experience of of you
know basically re-releasing or
recreating some of those old iconic
tracks it was basically me thinking how
am i going to make some money out of
banjo because everybody else's
that was that was the first thought i
thought that's man i'm gonna make some
money on this i mean i haven't still yet
um
i just thought i thought this would be
really great fun thing to do it was
absolutely like pulling teeth i hated
every second of it no way
remix on my music was just like oh god
this is tedious i just hated it i liked
it when i finished it i liked it but
dude it was like such a pain in the ass
what specifically was it about it that
you didn't enjoy i just don't know just
like going over it again like oh this
couldn't be retreading on ground
well it was that but plus i thought most
people when they remixed my stuff they
tried to probably do it exactly as it is
in the right in the same order like
reverse chords for whatever it is you
know and i thought there's nobody doing
that i'm going to do something different
so i was trying to reinvent it do metal
versions and
thin synth pop versions and i don't know
whatever i could think of at the time
eight-bit versions are not you know so
i've tried to think of other things
other ways to arrange it just got to be
such a pain in the ass must take me two
years to do it probably longer in fact
they're just really like oh my god
forever to do it wow so i'm so glad i
got it when i was like
i'm sick
uh well if you would like to plug it
where can people find it so you can make
that banjo money it's everywhere spotify
apple you know amazon everywhere i think
it's great no i know it's you turn up
one and people seem to like it honestly
i have i've thought i think it might be
another one i can't believe i'm saying
that don't that seems like a bad idea
you're going to hang out but what i
thought i'd do is i thought this time
i'll pick tracks from games up
not one game pick my favorite bits of
any game stick it together it's like not
the greatest tits but you know how does
that work licensing wise like do you are
you just allowed to like with with reed
jiggy did you have to go to microsoft
no you're not allowed to not not at all
so what you do what you do is like
there's quite a few um internet
companies like sound drops or another
one that i use and they take care of the
license
so
you give them the tracks as long as that
you can i can only release
certain tracks from banjo tracks that
have been released before that the lot
but the rule is it has to be released
before on so on an album or something
you can't pick an attack you like it has
to be it has to be existed as a
soundtrack somewhere interesting yeah so
i just picked the ones that i could
because i thought i'd do that i couldn't
so you give you ten dollar tracks so
they're making it all that they pay and
they pay max off the roads i think it's
10 cents attractive something like that
and then i get the rest of it they take
some money they take a cut of it and
that's what it seems so funny that it's
music that you made that then somebody
else owns that you're remaking that you
have to then pay the other person
because they bought it off of you even
though you made it
you know i only recommend money like the
only way i could do it was to call it a
cover version of my own stuff no way i
know what to paint in the house that's
so yeah again it makes sense i
understand it you know you worked at a
company when you made those and that
company got bought by another company by
another company but it's just it's so
interesting that you you did that and
that you don't own it can't
it's very weird to think about well i
don't i completely don't i mean i think
in america you keep you're supposed to
keep the writers share so i think that's
legally mine which is 50 of the track so
like when they when you go to the
performing rights things like um ascap
or bmi one of those everyone's remember
one of those right um
it's when you
list your tracks on the on their site so
they complete certain fine cut collect
the cash for you yeah um from like radio
plays or whatever
the writers show it's 50 you can only
have 50 percent that's yours and if
other writers just put features between
them yeah and then the other 50 goes to
the publisher which is in that case
would be i guess
it's microsoft or rare right so so it
works like that so i'm not sure if that
works the same place in every other
country but it definitely works like
that here interesting i mean it's
probably different music's such a
minefield where life is concerned
yeah i feel like
that's i think i think it works like
that
but i'm sure pirates in the uk do it
that way
so
but
the mechanical part the bit that's just
from sales that just goes straight to
the people that own it yeah but i think
it's supposed to be like if you it was
performed on a tv show or a like for
instance um now that showed shameless it
says yes it was the uk show originally
got made remade in america yeah well
for some for some one of the episodes
but the kid was playing banjo because he
were in the telly on the tv
anyway and so i even if you go look at
this you can't hear it he's not i can't
see i haven't seen it i went to look at
it i couldn't see it must be in the
background but i but i started getting
rolled it's looking tiny from that turn
up for this for them somebody somehow
found it and so then you automatically
get royalties because banjo was there
yeah but then they must have reported it
because you have to you know for the tv
shows and movies
yes they might have told yeah so they
feel they fill it in and they would have
put in vancouver banjo over to wherever
it was um
on that that queue and then the prs you
know ask him will pick that up and start
paying me he's bugger off good streaming
rights it's the rotten the tiny yeah if
that had been on terrestrial tv yeah it
would have been a decent amount of cash
wow humans crap you know
you know both kind of cbs bbc
it's on that
that you can make serious money out of
that do you just really want people on
the bbc if anyone from bbc's listening
that's right please play banjo because
you'll eat any
until later but you know monty norman
wrote about the james bond theme team
right now yes
and he's very tedious about that so we
had the rights to use it um but like i
found out i think later years he got a
50 cent royalty on the cartridge
so i think sold 10 million copies
so you got like five million quid just
to do that for
wow i know yeah foster never tells me
any of this stuff
jeez
you said this i didn't find out later
but i mean yeah you got that you gotta
roll it in the country so damn yeah i
mean like you know and like
that theme tune you know
that tune right but it goes but it goes
to the
jazzy part of the end right that's
clearly john barry yeah right and the
first bits but monty noble would never
even took the court off and he would
never give in to john barry and never
gave him the rights to that part of the
team
no he never gave in and if he he's got
little demo of that that tune right it's
like an indian sitar team you know like
that's
like that didn't dig
that kind of yeah that's right his first
recording of that tune was was like that
and he converted it it makes sense i
never thought about it before but yeah
it's crazy oh yeah like i said you never
gave me this it's mine it's mine it's
mine good idea
but the thing is like as a composer if
you can write one tune like that you
just have to give up that point there's
no point anymore that's it just give up
take the money
what about the love of music grant class
of course
of course the love of music
yeah that i mean that that's fascinating
and uh i could talk to you for forever
um but we are at about uh out of time 40
minutes yeah is there is there anything
else that you wanted to touch on like
regarding um
uh rejigging like i was going to be like
you know this part of it if you want to
promote any of it or anything
you i think everyone that knows about
this probably knows about it right now
probably so
you know it's out there go listen to it
you can see you think of it and i might
do another one
but they did funny enough even though
i can't believe i'm saying i really feel
like you shouldn't but i think thank you
another way to do the dk wrap even
though i've valve i've never touched
that again
and i just even though i just i don't i
don't know if i can even improve myself
to think about just that i was in the
shower i had an idea i thought bloody
hell that might work oh my
and it kind of kind of involves you a
little bit as much funny enough
and other people of your your ilk
that's exciting i know i just did an
idea i thought i don't know how to get
around to doing it but i just even
though i just thought i'd never touch
that such a bad
when it came out
so
that's amazing i mean i feel like as
your friend i should tell you um don't
do that
you'll hate it but i'm also excited and
interested at the same time so i will
not commit to my discouragement well
that took me another five years to get
there but i'll think about it yeah yeah
dude take that time for your mental
health to recover from reaching that's
right
that's right but thank you for chatting
me great i don't doubt that i'll i'll
want to chat to you again sometime this
is super interesting uh well thanks
thanks for asking me of course where can
people find you yeah you know twitter's
my main one i suppose i'm not a
superstar like you but twitter i suppose
on the instagram a little bit you're my
favorite influencer